but the question I want to ask
is I watch all of these videos and you
with absolutely no
fear no sense of propriety just going in
and a lot of them are just drop down I
mean the leotard one I was laughing out
loud
why are you the way that you are
well I like I said when my parents got
divorced Michael they fought for custody
of our family dog Primo more than me so
I was actually raised by a German
Shepherd more than I was by a two-parent
home so I come from the BLM Playbook of
the broken home and just like Saul
alinsky's Rules for Radicals and saying
Playbook to Barack Obama and all these
freak shoes on the left I'm using it on
the conservative movement I'm basically
using the rules for radical and using
the projection and just projecting all
of their crazy lunacy like the fact that
Leah Thomas swam on the men's team for
three years and then was able to take
some sort of medicine some you know
hormone therapy and was able to compete
against the women and become a national
champion in multiple events so it's
ludicrous it's absurd but that's where
we live in a world where the Supreme
Court Justice cantaji Brown Jackson
can't even Define what a woman is and I
know that is a Hot Topic in the daily
wire Community for the daily wire fans
you know that angle actually makes a lot
of sense to me because sometimes when I
watch your videos listen call me
old-fashioned bro sometimes I think ah
you know he's going a little far this is
a little much you know but but then the
way that you've just described it where
you say yeah I basically do what the
left does but I do it for the
conservatives I think well you know
there there's pretty much nothing that
I've seen you do that is any more
offensive than anything the left does
and it's probably much less offensive I
mean the left is killing babies and
trans and kids so obviously you know you
uh being sort of vulgar or something
like that is kind of in a completely
different category is that a is that is
that the idea behind this
performance art in many ways I guess I
would call it
well 100 my biological father Tucker
Carlson kind of coined it with me it's
called culture Jammy where you take the
most absurd parts of our culture and you
jamming their face but it's funny you
say that though Michael because I was
recently the host of a concert with a
guy named Bryson gray Forgiato blow and
a guy named Tyson James with her
conservative rappers and Vice news came
and covered it and at the end of the
event it was a successful event there's
400 people was fun we asked the vice
reporter because she actually kind of
had fun she was being nice and I have a
little heat advice uh for my
confrontation with Tesson but that's
neither here nor there back to my point
she said the only alarming thing to her
the whole entire event which was a
family-friendly event no cussing Bryson
is a secular rapper he doesn't even cuss
and I did jokes where I didn't cuss or
anything she said oh I didn't like that
there were so many children here because
there were a lot of kids a lot of
parents you know parents brought their
kids there
and then we asked her but what about
drag queen for story time and she's like
uh it's different so these people
literally want to sexualize children and
have them being read story times by men
in thongs that's okay that's social
justice but if you say abortion is bad
and that we want to save babies then
you're evil even people like Elizabeth
Warren that says crisis pregnancy
centers are demonic and satanic she says
they're the bad ones no one's trying to
save a life so that's how we're in the
upside down world I'm not even funny
Saturday Night Live isn't funny right
because they're too afraid of being
Politically Incorrect I'm Politically
Incorrect so I'm funny by default just
because I'm filling a void it's not even
that hard Michael so what what got you
started because I'm trying to think of
the first time I saw you it was
relatively recently So within the last
year or so and it was probably at one of
these school boards or something and I
thought man this is wild I haven't seen
a performance art like this in a very
long time and oh man the guy is is a
right winger and you know and I just
kept seeing you pop up where did you
come from I mean am I did was I missing
some 10-year career or something before
this that I just hadn't been aware of we
definitely need to do the hour-long
conversation but basically I started I
worked for a TV show Cheaters and I
signed an India I can only say so much
but the host of it was a very good
friend of mine named Clark Gable he died
of a fentanyl drug overdose he bought
pills that he thought were he bought
like Street Vicodin or whatever pain
pills and had Fentanyl and he died he
was very close friends of them they said
Alex you're going to be the next host of
cheaters then when it came April 2020
and I'm like in the best shape of my
life this is my big opportunity because
I had worked in television I also sold
cars on the side literally selling used
cars that's why I love creating content
imagine getting on the hot pavement at
110 degrees for Hispanic guy to show you
that there's a car leaking the
transmission's leaking it's not that fun
you know I'm just saying doing this and
playing make-believe you know making fun
of politicians is much easier but my
point being is at right when I was
supposed to get the job they picked a 52
year old black guy named Peter Gunz who
God for you know God bless him he's
definitely good that he took the job but
my point being the show is syndicated by
Viacom so they changed his name from
Peter Gunz to Peter Panky and they just
didn't want another kind of 30 year old
white guy they wanted to go a different
direction which just makes sense but for
me it was a little bit of an affirmative
action and that kind of radicalized me
to be like hey I need to create my own
podcast I need to create my own thing so
Michael when I go to these meetings at
the beginning of the pandemic I went to
the mayor Dallas and was dead serious
was like you know why are we closing the
parks they turn off the water fountains
that my dogs drink out of at the park
you know and this is April in Texas it's
hot like how does this stop the spread
of anything and they looked at me like
and I was I was the biggest idiot in the
world just oh who is this conspiracy
theorist I mean just didn't show me any
attention and then when I noticed the
more absurd I got the more uncomfortable
they felt and I turned those NPCs those
non-playable characters of politicians
Intel oh now I can control them all I
want because now they have to get mad at
me they have to kick me out they have to
be embarrassed so yeah it's kind of just
it started off you know earnestly and
then I realized what's the most
effective is like I keep saying those
rules for articles is that we have to do
you know District times call called
cause for desperate measures whatever
the saying is we cannot use these uh
Orthodox tactics of being nice and
respectful we have to somehow use humor
to break people away or free from this
trauma-based mind control that the
mainstream media has everybody under so
how much of the ACT is you know a
sincere reflection of your political
views and how much of it is this sort of
olinskiite working around the system
because you know if we're locked into
this system the liberal establishment is
just going to continue to rule how much
of it is intentionally you know you you
say something you don't believe or you
you know you act in a way that you
wouldn't ordinarily act just to just to
get them to jump out of their ordinary
trains of thought
yeah well I mean you could say like
shock factor for shock Factor but let me
tell you my political leanings is I'm a
populist I actually even though I'm now
a few more conservative I am a tin foil
hat proud tinfoil hat wearing conspiracy
theories I believe the weapons of mass
destruction that we never found in the
Middle East the 20-year war that we had
I just think that the government will
lie to us and they will pull all sorts
of tricks and I think the pandemic woke
a lot of people up to that so my point
being is when you have the populist
mindset and you know you want to say oh
I'm conservative I want the government
left out of everything but at the same
time when I sold cars the government
made sure that I gave them an inspection
if I didn't give a customer an
inspection then you know I could be
liable to getting in trouble if I sold
them a lemon so it's kind of good that
the government gets involved in some
stuff but I don't want them because they
mess everything up but when it comes to
the Health Care System why is it that
insulin costs 200 in Texas but it's
seven dollars in Mexico but if I want to
get 10 000 vaccines that's all free so
we need a reallocation of funds now I'm
not saying we should have free health
care but we should make health care more
affordable I think that would just
benefit Society so even though I'm more
conservative if I really kind of
consider myself in the middle when it
comes to my political leanings I don't
like to say that I'm ultra far right
that's what they label me proud boy far
right when in reality that's that's not
the case I mean I'm anti-abortion
obviously there's some huge stuff that
I'm you know really staunch on that you
would say that's super conservative but
at the same time it's like I'm not
against Social Services I'm not against
helping people but letting a hundred
thousand uh you know drug overdose
happens because of fentanyl this past
year just having a wide open border
that's creating a welfare state I'm not
down with that so I like to consider
myself somewhere in the middle
foreign
[Music]
[Music]